we got another relationship bro this one
might be near and dear to uh
to brendon's heart how's it going
brendan
dio got a quick question for you
relationship
advice as i'm wearing that merch emerge
is it worth it that hot passion latina
love
when they're out here doing things like
this
oh breaking everything i love that's my
xbox and guitarsy
but then after the storm
comes the love yes four days later she
bought me a brand new xbox
is it worth it that crazy love when one
second everything you love and own
is broken and shattered but then come
sweet kisses
love and passion like never before
is it worth it let me know y'all love
you guys
gang gang buzz buzz
yeah that's a fake king of sting shirt
but whatever um
listen man i'd have to see the latina
though because you just worth it you got
to walk through some fire to get
through the storm you feel me then the
the sun always comes out after a storm
usually it's worth if they're bad enough
stick with it my man
yeah brennan's also trying to save his
marriage so he's saying that but what
i'm going to say is this
what i'm going to say is this bro this
is the beginning
of how this is going to be a very de
peligroso
dangerous bro environment like i admire
any man i admire brendan i admire
cesar chavez his wife any man that is
willing to
take on a latina woman because they are
dangerous bro they're vatas
dude a lot of them they sleep at night
but barely you know they're [ __ ] just
so
in in their mind they're awake doing
[ __ ] tattoo art and [ __ ] they just
you know they're very dangerous and
she's gonna this is the beginning of
things getting smashed you're gonna
smash your bank account she's gonna
smash
she's gonna smash five kids in your life
dude four kids
at least nah dog you know it's dude some
flaming hot cheetos and a dick suck
there ain't nothing better dude
keep writing this out and it's worth it
man end of this laptop
especially if they're in that order too
i want to say that what i'm saying bro
stick with it dog i'm just worried a
little worried about that dog she said
he said everything he loves uh that
might be next if they get it
that's the price you gotta pay due to
get with the latino she's bad enough
you're gonna sacrifice that little hound
you feel me kill bro
yeah man the mono that rocks the cradle
papa you feel me
so those were good uh relationship
advices keep sending those in those are
fun
um but yeah dude look invite us to your
funeral also please write down somewhere
on your nightstand or whatever
if you come up missing uh
that we get to go to your funeral i
think that'd be awesome field trip for
us yeah i also asked your girl to film
it if she does murder you king or
stinging it murder my white boyfriend
or film anything and send it to us dude
i'm [ __ ] lonesome
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying dude and in my
city lonely guys are [ __ ] killing
themselves
how about that bomber at the [ __ ]
downtown nashville sting some lonely
dude in a camper
i thought it was ari mantis bro i
thought it was
yeah he tried getting rid of 5g is ari
living in nashville in his camper
no but i'm sure he will be soon
[Music]